guck mal auch welche mit ihren platz
aber du kannst das doch gehöre ich muss
natürlich aber ich habe jetzt noch
weggeschickt möchten selbst einsetzen
müsse und jetzt mal überhaupt
vorbeigekommen hier und da zeigen wie
das aussieht
[Musik]
so wird das ganze wieder blendet trotz
knapp und herzlich willkommen bei einem
neuen video ja leute ich hoffe natürlich
geht's gut
das musst du weiter beziehungsweise
heute hat alex die pakete an
die wissen gar nicht welche pakete wir
haben ein video in dem ich empfinde ich
mir alles bei apple stellte was ich
geschafft habe
ok also wir haben letztens ein video
gedreht in dem ich mir fünf minuten
alles aussuchen durfte bremsen was ich
heute bz was ich geschafft habe in der
zeit und es sind genau vier säuren hast
du geschafft
alex hat die sachen halt irgendwann mit
zwei sachen sind noch nicht da aber da
ist bei den ganzen sachen eigentlich um
halloween geht haben wir gedacht das
müssen wir jetzt machen also die
halloween sachen sind alle da so weit
ich weiß in köln regnete es so heftig
und diese sachen war nicht wie immer bei
der poststelle hier gegenüber sondern
die waren in irgend einer packstation
ich stand da im regen zehn minuten und
musste diese sachen herauskriegen ich
habe so etwas noch nie gemacht ich
wusste überhaupt nicht wie das geht
erklärt dann irgendwann funktioniert
weil ich war die letzten tage hatte ich
hier also wenn ihr das video noch nicht
gesehen habe wo sie sich das alles
bestellt hat schaut euch das erste mal
ist in der video beschreibung verlinkt
wir fangen erst mal mit diesen bringen
und zwar ist es glaube ich die tasche
deswegen machen
jetzt rede ich jetzt dafür dass ich dir
gekauft hat sozusagen wo dann können wir
gar nicht platz
ich möchte sagen was sie von dem kampf
einsetzen kann hahaha das ist das ach so
kommt man kann die einbrechenden interne
tasche ist der mir drei taschen zusammen
ja echt geil
alles von kevin kline also leute
eigentlich soll es in dem video um
halloween sachen gehen weil die kommen
jetzt aber noch ne also das war auch
dabei paszek war nicht von innen also da
muss ich sagen finde ich aber so waren
die louis vuitton tasche schön obwohl
ich das hier eine gar nicht also leute
tasche wie immer in der video beschreibt
die verlinkt so ging es um sowas unrecht
nicht so leute machen weit fahren mit
dem ersten halloween artikeln und zwar
ist das glaube ich sogar nur einer von
vier halloween artikeln die wir heute
dabei habt ja weil wir haben ja auch
noch hier bestellt ich muss sagen ich
habe ich schon mal reingeguckt zumindest
habe ich unsicher was ist das bitte
schön
viele sachen auf einmal poetischen
sorgen das ist kein bock dabei gibt aber
das schlimmste was ist passiert und was
willst du da sein ich weiß gar nicht
mehr was center also wenn ich mir das
jetzt hier so gekokelt zumindest das
hier kann das auch was anderes sein als
wechseln
also wenn ihr noch keine idee habt
gelogen ich weiß etwas kurzfristig je
nachdem die eier
na ja wir gucken jetzt erst mal wie das
aussieht also wir haben ja dass dinge
bin ich mal gespannt wie das aussieht
okay ich war gutachter ob das ist das
jetzt genau das zu meinen
rockstar wurde auch noch ein hexenhut
weiß nicht neun punkte doch erst mal aus
jetzt das ist das seminar als netz
handschuhe
daher kann ich mich irgendwie gar nicht
mehr erinnern dass du die bestellt hast
echt nicht da kann es mal sehen was ich
für den fixen ich meine finger noch was
genau so tut man hier seinen normalen
oder was gemacht
also ich will mal sein da kann man auf
jeden fall jetzt mal richtig dicken
daumen nach oben geben mir oder leute
als letztes haben wir hier noch augen
für kontaktlose man die ziehst du an das
hab ich mir überlegt ja und ich habe mir
überlegt dass sie doch für dein auto ist
es eigentlich um die uhr am tierblut
dass diese kapsel kann so drauf weist
dann einfach
drum kit raus meint sich um direkte noch
damit recht hast du dich also die haben
wir vampir kapseln das ist gut weil ich
alle schmecken wird flüssigkeit bei
räder kommen wir eines der behälter guck
mal zeit richtig dass die richtig gute
hallo leute ich würde sagen bevor wir
jetzt hier weiterhin heißen euro märz
ist es soweit
ich möchte einmal ein video zu sehen wie
du dich an
ja aber nein jetzt tue ich das auch für
leute die nicht wissen wie man eine
kontaktlinse einsatz also ich hab ja ich
hatte noch nie in meinem leben eine
kommt ein bild nach elster deiner nase
hin nicht zu machen
das bringen wird all das können wir
machen und kurze aber gut da ich heute
wird schon das aber du kannst doch gehör
nicht tust du dich ja ich habe jetzt
noch möglich die selbst eingesetzten wir
dann macht euch die busse nach innen zur
nase hin darf sich nicht dazu gehört ja
man das ist reflex ich kann doch nicht
spielen so leute noch einiges mehr
changing autorität jetzt noch mal gucken
wie das aussehen was wir bestellt hast
ne sechseinhalb stunden später jetzt
kommt auch die kontaktlosen und dann ist
das so fix fertig oder bis 100 oder
[Musik]
boah mach mal die andere auch noch weit
leute also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich will das gar nicht mal stellt das
sieht schon recht professionell aus also
wirklich und gutes kostüm trend dass
gerade das nimmt ja sieht gut aus für
mich so leute das outfit von marie ist
jetzt fertig ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
ich finde es gar nicht mal schlecht also
kann man halloween auf jeden fall gut
tragen denke ich mal ihr könnt ja gern
mal irgendeine kommentar schreiben
einfach wir mal von eins bis zehn
bewerten und jetzt kannst du überhaupt
vorbeikommen hier waren dann mal zeigen
wie das aussieht
ich fange unten an gute schuhe kann man
ja noch diesen schwarzen look passen
oder egal was hier aus gut dann haben
wir hier dieses wir heißt dass
sonderburg dann hier die corsa und jetzt
kann es einmal jeden gucken also das
sieht echt die augen gefallen mir am
besten
die sind wie kannst du immer so haben
nicht das von den augen zu drehen
er ist auf jeden fall nach diesem
auftritt und das war's mit dem kleinen
halloween unboxing von dem besten video
jobs hat euch gefallen lässt nur nach
oben
wir sehen uns morgen wieder da gibt es
für mich zum zum friseur echt so also
heute haut rein und dann kommt